freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video zu einem besonderen video
erst ich bin ein bisschen da sah ich
habe gestern morgen zwei striche gehabt
wenn ihr versteht was ich meine und bin
dementsprechend jetzt hier zu hause
eingesperrt und ihr bleibt nur eine
sache an der ich noch freude habe
nämlich essen und genau das werden wir
jetzt tun mit dem islam eine freundin
hinter der kamera die steht das ganze
mit mir durch und ich werde ja schon
gesehen bei restaurants anrufen und
sagen ey bringt mir die letzte
bestellung hier bekommen habt einfach
nochmal das habe ich mir überlegt dass
kann ich super gut jetzt gerade drehen
um die zeit habe ich alle male deshalb
malt das ganze jetzt hoffen nur dass das
ganze funktioniert und ich kann ja kein
geld wohin gehen ich habe 50 euro ich
hoffe das kommt auch bei
max wieder kurze frage ihr liefert auch
selbst aus oder
das ist schade okay es geht das wieder
los wird erst beim letzten mal hat es so
lange gedauert wie man zu finden einfach
selbst ausliefert
ihr selbst aus
liefert dir auch essen
bei ihr selbst aus
hey kurze frage liefert dir selbst aus
sondern und lieferanten oder so
dass jetzt mehr zu als die krankheit so
ich habe einen laden gefunden bei dem
sollte das jetzt auf jeden fall klappen
ist ein italiener dort hob ich jetzt an
und ich hoffe dass ich was gutes
bekommen beziehungsweise dass die
personen vor mir was gutes bestellt hat
yar'adua hatte die fahrt selbst aus oder
super okay ich hab euch eine spezielle
frage ich würde gerne einfach bestellen
was zuletzt bericht bestellt wurde
einfach genau die gleiche bestellung
genau also egal egal was das ist
nein sie sie verstehen nicht falsch ich
will einfach was der letzte kunde
bestellt hat egal wie egal was genau das
will ich bekomme einfach weil es lustig
ist
[Musik]
genau die hat mir die gleiche bestellung
wie der letzte kunde hatte super danke
schön ja ok kleine
kommunikationsschwierigkeiten aber ich
sollte jetzt die letzte bestellung
bekommen und ich habe keine ahnung was
es ist deshalb einfach mal abwarten
hoffentlich sind jetzt keine fünf pizzen
ich lasse mich überraschen jetzt wollen
wir noch eine weitere adresse da werden
wir auch anrufen
hallo guten tag können sie mir einfach
bringen was der kunde vor mir bestellt
hat
super vielen dank da gefragt
ja es kein problem dank
das war eine schwere geburt leute aber
ich habe ein zweiter laden gefunden dh
jetzt heißt es warten ist das essen da
ist und ich hoffe dass die leute von mir
guten geschmack hatten
wir halten den ball ein bisschen flach
wir machen nur zweiten stellung heute
die erst ist schon hier ich weiß nicht
genau was es ist sie für mich aus ist
ein italienisches restaurant wird ihr
angerufen habe die ein auflauf irgendwas
also kennt man ja auch diese klassische
verpackung wir schauen jetzt einfach mal
rein was wir hier keines haben
[Musik]
okay man weiß dass wir das können so
cannelloni sein es könnte eigentlich
alles mögliche sein wie sie auf jeden
fall die ganze angelegenheit kann auch
super schnell und rasant das gute ist
leute ich hatte ich angst davor
irgendwann mal positiv zu sein weil ich
mir dachte alter da kannst du nichts
mehr schmecken und
ihr könnt euch vorstellen für meine
videos und dementsprechend auch für mich
ist es sehr wichtig dass ich schmecken
kann aber unicom hat gar keinen
geschmacksverlust noch ganz ganz selten
weshalb werde keine größere sorgen
machen muss wir haben hier also eine
lasagne 9 euro 50 auch super ferne ohne
lieferte gehörten eur 50.000
dazu gibt es pizza brötchen ich probiert
erstes dann bist du dran aber ich sage
ehrlich essen es wirklich das was mir am
meisten spart noch gar nichts von diäten
davor und jetzt habe ich wieder so
richtig reinzuhauen und ist vielleicht
nicht das beste aber ich schneide jetzt
hier einmal die lasagne an
ok probiere einfach machen
hmm also obwohl ich ja zu naiv kann ich
trotzdem auf folgenden strecken ist es
noch ein bisschen knusprig tor eine
grundsolide da sagen ja also ich weiß
nicht was ich sagen soll wie schön
cremig somit dieser die chance die pasta
hat guten bis der käse so wenn man
knusprig um braucht
also für 950 ist also dafür sind
wirklich kraft pizza wo ich hier noch
im auch normal ich sage ehrlich
vollkommen zu ziehen jetzt bin ich
gespannt ob das auch sagen dass wir
jetzt auch einmal du bist ja auch
bekannt als sanierer experten
[Musik]
expertenmeinung abgeschlossen ist
wirklich nur lecker ist aber auch nur
eine einzige sache deshalb hoffe ich mal
dass bei der nächsten bestellung paar
mehr sachen kommen werden aber wir
lassen uns überraschen
zweite bestellung und sie ist deutlich
umfangreicher ausgefallen durch das war
ein bisschen über 40 euro dafür bezahlt
wahrscheinlich nirgendwo familie
bestellt wenn es zwei drei personen die
ordentlich hunger hat machen wir einfach
mal auf max weber
krank es ist ein koreanisches restaurant
gewesen und er mir so eine saison wurde
frühlingsrollen und so eine knusprige
reispapier rolle hier drin nummer zwei
dass sie wirklich sehr geil aus oder
einfach nur eishockey hier haben wir
einmal
ist dass dieses buch mein haar 9
und bonobo das kenne ich das bestelle
ich immer woanders ist übelst geil aber
ich habe es da noch nie vergessen ich
habe generell noch nicht bei dem daten
gegessen haben wir einmal die hartz iv
sieht auch keine auszutoben gemüse
also vom optischen her sieht das crazy
aus und dann haben wir hier noch
christi zeigt die asiatischen
spezialität christi zeigt haben wir
einmal sehr sehr geil also es sind quasi
so ein paar vorspeisen und zwei
hauptspeicher und ich werde mich jetzt
durch diese frittierten köstlichkeiten
einmal durch test nicht vegan ist das
ganze hier sogar
so klassisches studium voll
hier weiß nicht mal was das ist aber
schon mal so richtig fett gedrängt wenn
man das so sieht alles könnte man denken
ist wieder gesund ist es ja auch zuteil
die dinge hier auf jeden fall nicht
[Musik]
so gelassen sehr sehr köstlichkeit das
vor allem dieses andere uci und hier die
christi zeigt probiere ich jetzt auch
einmal
fleisch gemüse finde ich sehr sehr geil
ist der herzhaft bisher alles krass von
dem laden wirklich alles kraft der sonne
sommer wolle er noch nie so eine
sonderrolle gestellt weil ich mir
irgendwie immer dachte ja kann das geil
sein kann darin tofu sesam super fresh
wirklich ganz ganz so frisch das ganze
hier
wenn ich beide davon esse ich wieder
gesund das ist das ist so hält die zwei
stücke forderung die kraft ist da aber
es schmeckt auch nicht mal scheint es
ist ein krankes kontrastprogramm zu
diesen ganzen importierten dingen aber
dieses gesunde so schneller test er hat
noch salat reis nudeln sieht auch schon
wieder aus das habe ich wirklich in
meiner diät diätphase die eine woche
angehalten paar mal gegessen und ich bin
gespannt wie es hier schmecken
diese rindfleisch greifen die sind so
präzise mariniert bolt trat nur
stückchen dazu war wirklich sehr sehr
kasse der sehr lecker und zu guter letzt
nehmen hier einmal reinschauen das ist
zwar auch wieder alles betty mit
kilometer und so aber da ist auf jeden
fall auch nur gute ecke höher ran also
aber das schadet auch ordentlich ist im
kreis dazu ein schöner trieb
ride-anlage
häftlinge haben diese vorspeise
überhaupt die sagen hier heißt komfort
andere als manuell weit verfehlt wird
war es zeit für deine mutter
[Musik]
die für eine
wilfried sorgen macht seinem namen alle
ehre oder
oha und hermann probier mal kritisch
alcoa das ist so richtig ist oder eine
zwiebel stylus oder
ich habe das auch irgendwie vorgesehen
[Musik]
dass für richtige das merkt wirklich
nach sommer haben deswegen sommer wieder
mal eine geile methode kann man wieder
von der backe blitz streichen komische
methode um irgendwelche zu essen zu
bekommen er hat funktioniert war super
lecker irgendwie werde ich nie
enttäuscht so was ich weiß auch nicht
wahrscheinlich glaubt ihr ist mir auch
gar nicht wenn ich sage das was lecker
ist aber alles wieder top heute ein
weiteres video werde ich wahrscheinlich
auch noch von ihr zuhause drehen müssen
und dann wenn ich auch wieder in
freiheit danke fürs zu sehen dank fürs
mitmachen ich hoffe dass christa zeuke
schmeckt sehr gut und bis zur nächsten
video max kutscher